in politics a gaffe is when some
politician
accidentally tells the truth gen saki
our favorite current white house press
secretary committed a big
gaffe over the past few days when after
weeks of steadfastly refusing to
call the situation or southern border a
crisis
she accidentally slipped and called it
like it is
were there expectations set with the
mexicans that they helped deal with the
situation on the board
there have there have been expectations
set outside of
unrelated to any vaccine doses or
requests for them
that they would be partners in dealing
with the crisis on the border
the reporter calls it a situation at the
border the reporter's holding the party
line
jensaki though because you know
not she doesn't always have the best
answers she accidentally tells the truth
and we've got new information the crisis
is
way way worse than anybody is letting on
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from paul gold
who says it's hilarious when corrupt
politicians but i repeat myself
always start off their lies by saying
let me be perfectly clear
that actually means that they will be
lying or evading the question with swamp
speak
this is true when politicians obama did
this a whole lot
joe biden did this a lot let me be
perfectly clear and then he'd just go on
and lie to you it's sort of like when
people say
hey to be honest or
listen honestly because it
it suggests that they haven't been
honest with you up until this point
let me be perfectly clear say like well
i haven't been perfectly clear with you
and i probably won't be clear with you
right
now in these sort of chaotic times it's
good to have some tangible things you
can rely on
like physical gold acre gold great way
to invest in physical gold you know the
price of gold has been
skyrocketing lately now there is a way
to buy gold through a company called
acre that will not force you to shell
out everything
all at once you can subscribe through
acre to gold bars for as little as 30
a month but michael that's not possible
gold costs more than 30
well that's true but acres figured out
this ingenious way where you pay each
month and once your gold stash reaches
the price of their gold bars they will
discreetly ship
acre gold to your house just recently
acre has introduced a new 100
a month subscription to their five gram
gold bar
also you know that there's a nationwide
ammo shortage well acre is crafting a
solid gold
24 karat 9 millimeter bullet for you to
buy right now they're not making a ton
of these so
get it now it's extremely cool i guess i
should tell you
you're really not supposed to shoot
these bullets unless you were aiming
right at the heart of a werewolf
uh head on over i mean this is really
terrific i love
uh investing in precious metals i've
enjoyed that in my life
visit getacregold.com michael start
investing in physical gold today make
sure you go to this url because acres
giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre
that's getacregold.com michael thank you
akergold for supporting the show
the crisis at the border is a crisis
that joe biden has made he isn't the
cause
of the entire crisis he's not the reason
from the very beginning that there are
any illegal aliens that are
crossing our border that has been going
on for a long time
joe biden's been in politics a long time
and his policies have have
exacerbated that but we're talking about
what's happening
right now the record numbers of people
unaccompanied minors accompanied minors
and foreign nationals generally
who are pouring across this border right
now during
the supposedly deadly unprecedented
pandemic
where we are not permitted to leave our
houses and go
hang out down the street at a restaurant
or go to church
at the same time you've got record
numbers of foreign nationals pouring
across our border
many of whom are not tested for
coronavirus
this is being caused by joe biden his
policies
are leading to the historic numbers that
we're seeing you don't need
gensake to tell you that you don't need
me to tell you that
illegal aliens themselves are saying
this to journalists journalists have not
been permitted into the
detention facilities for the illegals
unlike
any other previous administration
there is essentially no transparency at
these detention facilities
but sometimes the journalists are able
to catch them in various
other places and martha raddatz on abc
was speaking to an
illegal alien saying why are you here
why'd you do it the answer
mr biden would you have tried to do this
when donald trump was president
definitely not
definitely we had the chance you know
the the same violence that is going on
today was there last year we used to
watch the news and uh
i definitely won't do this so did you
come here because
joe biden was elected president
basically
basically uh the main thing was the
violence in my country
the main thing was the violence in my
country but the next thing
was that joe biden is president
that is something that anyone with any
common sense
already knows and interesting that abc
news martha raddatz not exactly a
conservative outlet or conservative
reporter but the story is so clear that
they're at least
bringing this to the forefront this
illegal alien won't show his face
obviously because he's doing something
illegal but he's saying look
joe biden is essentially inviting me
across the border at many times during
the
2020 presidential campaign he said you
should surge the border you should come
to the border and he's saying
the main reason is because there's
violence in my country
maybe that's true or maybe just broadly
speaking his country isn't that nice and
our country is a lot nicer
he says but after that the reason i'm
doing it now
the immediate cause is joe biden yeah
makes perfect sense of course
i don't think that we can say that joe
biden is entirely to blame and this
guy's not to blame it all
because this guy is doing something
illegal this guy is breaking
the law of a very sacred law
to a country and that's the first act
he's going to to perform in that country
so
he is doing something wrong he should
know better and it's very
sad that his country's no good but the
answer is not just for everyone from
every no good country to flee and come
to our country that's not going to work
and to break our laws while doing it
still biden bears a lot of blame here
our politicians should enforce the law
particularly our politicians in the
executive branch
and they're not doing it they're doing
the opposite it's not merely that
they're looking the other way
it's not merely that they're taking
their eyes off the ball
they are actively encouraging this wave
of immigration
the biden administration is allowing the
release of illegal border crossers into
the u.s
without even scheduling a court date
so at least ordinarily if they're going
to start releasing people into the u.s
they'll pretend that there's going to be
any sort of justice they're at least
going to say okay you've got to show up
in court
on this date and usually they don't show
up in court but the biden administration
isn't even doing that they're just
saying see ya
enjoy good luck and but just remember
though once we give you amnesty you
gotta vote for us
don't forget that border patrol agents
in the rio
grande valley sector have begun to
process and release
illegal border crossers who claim asylum
without that notice
to appear this is unprecedented this has
never
happened before this is a being reported
according to fox
a place is the responsibility of seeking
an asylum hearing
on the migrants through ice or legal
assistance probably not going to happen
beyond that what if you
enter this country illegally and you're
not being turned away
but you know you don't have anywhere to
go what is going to happen i think a
sane country would say yeah the way to
go is right across that border
in the other direction right back where
you came from our country
under the biden administration just
awarded an
86 million dollar contract
for hotel rooms near the border to hold
some 1200 migrant family members
who illegally crossed our border this is
from dhs
officials confirming it to axios the
contract went to a texas-based
non-profit the contract of 86 million is
for six months
it could be extended it could be
expanded
these hotels are in arizona and texas
all areas right along the border
in this past year when your government
has told you that
it's so dangerous outside with this
virus
that you can't have thanksgiving you
can't have christmas you can't see your
friends
you can't bury your dead relatives you
can't have your weddings
you can't go to church because if you go
outside and maybe you're not vaccinated
you're not tested but even if you are
vaccinated
that's an a an historic public health
crisis
that same regime is spending 86 million
dollars
to bring in people foreign nationals
from countries that don't have such
great public health systems
without in many cases testing them for
coronavirus
and putting them up in hotels and then
releasing them into this country
often without a court date
somewhere someone is not playing in good
faith
the same people cannot be doing both of
those things
sincerely so who is it is it joe biden
well i'm not so sure is joe biden really
the one calling the shots you may have
seen this it happened on friday
joe biden tried to walk up a flight of
stairs and
he stumbled more than stumbled he fell
right down three times
we see him walking up the stairs to air
force one
mary stumbles there he falls again there
he just goes all the way down
rubs off his leg now he grabs onto both
railings makes it into the airplane
finally
very sad i don't want to make fun of an
elderly man
for falling down the stairs the staffers
tried to blame this on the wind if you
look at national weather service the
wind in that area
it was a light breeze was not heavy wind
this is just more affirmation
that joe biden is not the man he once
was
and fair enough if we you have relatives
who are 78 years old
do you think that they can run up and
down stairs all sprightly while they're
leading the free world
in some cases look there's some people
who can do it but generally speaking no
probably not so is he really calling the
shots
i also don't want to hear that bringing
up joe biden's fall
is cheap i don't want to hear that it's
unseemly
or that it's irrelevant give me a break
after what we heard from donald trump i
don't want to hear about it trump of
course
had some things to say about biden's
fall
i watched as uh joe biden went up the
stairs today
i said i didn't lose to him
almost 75 million votes and probably a
lot more than that
so there it is a classic rambling yeah i
watched him walk up the stairs
i did not lose to that guy okay i
there's no way that i it can't have
happened it's not possible okay and the
people laugh
and i'm sure he's gonna be you know
they're gonna increase his gulag
sentence now by 30 years for
spreading the misinformation of telling
a funny joke that rings true to a lot of
people because
biden's obviously not all with it but i
don't want to hear it
for to me that i shouldn't bring up
joe biden's stumbling and i don't want
to hear people say that donald trump
shouldn't have brought up
joe biden's stumbling because joe biden
did it himself
look at how he steps and look how i
stepped
watch how i run up ramps and he stumbles
down ramps okay
come on it's a legitimate question to
ask legitimate question to ask of both
of us
thank god my health is good but i'm a
great
i'm a great respecter of fate i realize
anything can happen to anybody at any
age any time
but i promise you i would not be running
unless i was in very good health i work
out every morning
and i am in relatively good shape as my
mother would say knock on wood
that's a legitimate question look how i
run up steps look how he
slides down ramps he's talking about how
at a west point game there was a
slippery
ramp no steps ramp so trump walked a
little bit more slowly than he usually
does
look at our run-up steps well we did joe
we are looking at that and joe biden
made an issue out of this
and the left made a big issue out of
this at the time and this feeds into
something that we all know
you might hate donald trump but i don't
think anybody thought that donald trump
was low energy in decline i mean this is
a guy who was working 24 hours a day
always extremely high energy dancing
around at his rallies
always got the vicious clever bob you
know jibe
at one of his opponents joe biden i
don't think we've been thinking that
and this raises now even more
questions i get a lot of questions when
i go to the auto parts store the brick
and mortar and i don't know the answer
to them which is why it's much much
better
to go to rockauto.com rockauto.com
always offers the lowest price as
possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts like let's say hypothetically
i'm just going to come up with this off
the top of my head because i'm a big
expert on cars
let's say you need a delphi fg145 fuel
pump assembly for 2005 to 2010 honda
odyssey and it costs i don't know i'm
going to say
354 at a big chain store that's the kind
of thing you can get at rock auto for
217 bucks
pretty good huh rockauto.com is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online
for 20 years head on over to
rockauto.com right now
spare yourself the humiliation of not
knowing you know exactly
this part or this type or whatever then
you go into the brick and mortar and
they charge you
twice as much i love how easy the
catalog is to navigate the prices are
reliably low
and it's the same prices for
professionals
as for do-it-yourselfers so go to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck then write knowles
k-w-l-e-s in there how did you hear
about us box so they know we sent you
now in addition to his comments on
joe biden's ability to walk and what
this means about joe biden's political
strength
president trump also has some news to
announce this i think a lot of people
have been suspecting is in the work for
a long time
president trump sent one of his aides
jason miller
on the news shows this weekend to
announce
that yes the president he is kicked off
twitter
yes the president is off of facebook and
instagram and youtube
uh yes the president has not chosen to
join any of the
alternative social media platforms like
gab
or like parlor but president trump will
be back to social media soon
because he's going to launch his own
social media platform
i do think that we're going to see
president trump returning to social
media in probably about two or three
months here
with his own platform and this is
something i think will be the
the hottest ticket in social media it's
going to completely redefine the game
and everybody is going to be waiting and
watching to see what exactly president
trump does but it will be his own
platform well i can't go
much further than what i was able to
just share but i can say that it will be
big once he starts
there's been a lot of high-powered
meetings he's been having at mar-a-lago
uh with some teams of folks who've been
coming in and i gotta tell you there
have been it's not just
one company that's approached the
president there have been numerous
companies
but i think the president does know what
direction that he wants to head here
and this new platform is going to be big
and everyone wants them he's going to
bring
millions and millions tens of millions
of people to this new platform
you're listening to jason miller speak
here i'm reminded of how much i miss the
kind of trump era
of republican politics uh hope
hopefully we have learned something from
that hopefully some version of that will
continue but just this like look it's
going to be the biggest it's the
greatest everybody wants in it's going
to be terrific and
frankly he's probably right i mean there
are going to be a lot a lot of people
who head on over to donald trump's
social media platform i'm looking
forward to seeing it
i think it's very important that
conservatives
assert their cultural and political
power
because the the field in which we're
allowed to play now in politics but also
economically
the the uh scope of things we're allowed
to say and allowed to do
is really shrinking and it's not just
being shrunk by big government
it's being shrunk by corporate america
it's being shrunk by the administrative
state it's being
shrunk by big tech it's being shrunk by
a lot of companies that are adopting
wokism
which brings me to a little bit of
personal news from this
show it actually pains me to relate this
but i i feel i have to do it i feel i
owe it to the listeners
to relate this we have a lot of
advertisers on this show
some of them share our values many of
them don't share our values
and that's perfectly fine we don't we
don't discriminate
based on the views of some company and
they tend not to discriminate based on
our views
and we think if we we can have a good
partnership and if they've got a good
product we want to bring that good
product
to the people who listen to this show
harry's razors seems to have a big issue
with us now and a big issue therefore
with our listeners
we found this out over the weekend a
twitter account that has
two followers that does not you know it
doesn't seem to be the most
prominent or legitimate real
twitter account came out and it
complained at harry's to try to get
harry's to drop
this show harry's razors and said
harry's razers is sponsoring michael
knowles
who is spreading homophobic and
transphobic content you know and
how did all the phobias and all the isms
and all that sort of thing
so harry's which has been a good partner
on the show and they make great razors
responded to this very small it would
seem not totally legitimate twitter
account
by saying thanks for bringing this up we
condemn the views in this video
what video is it we'll get to that in a
second we condemn the views in this
video which are inexcusable and at odds
with our longtime support of the lgbtq
plus
community we've ended our relationship
with this show
and are looking into our sponsorships to
prevent any values misalignment
going forward so i looked i said what
video are they talking about it's a
video where
i appeared on candace owens's show
at prageru years ago and we were
discussing
the transgender question and in
discussing that contradicted the sort of
politically correct view and said oh you
know maybe there's some questions here
right
i appeared on this show
a year i believe before harry's ever
started advertising on this show
the purpose of this show is to explore
the hot button political and cultural
issues
and offer a conservative perspective on
that
a perspective that is shared by tens and
tens of millions hundreds of millions
maybe of americans
but that is is not in line with the woke
politically correct fads
and and uh ideas that have really only
cropped up very recently
harry's knew that they knew all this
sort of stuff going in but when a a
twitter account with two people
following it takes a hit
to try to prevent uh conservatives from
having advertisers and therefore to
prevent conservatives from
i don't using good product using good
razors like hairy razors
they go in they buckle they spread this
then to their tens of thousands
of twitter followers and and they are
saying
we condemn the views in this video
they're saying we condemn the views
of conservative americans we think that
the views of conservative americans are
inexcusable
and at odds with our longtime views
advertisers cancel
on their campaigns with us sometimes and
then we get new advertisers sometimes
and that's totally fine there are plenty
of reasons why an advertiser
might cancel a campaign maybe we're just
not selling enough enough of their
product
maybe they don't like something that we
said
maybe i don't know maybe the wind blew
in a certain way in the morning and they
just had to change apart
that's all totally fine advertisers have
every single right to do that
it's just a very different thing when
instead of just
canceling their campaigns with us they
start attacking
not just us at daily wire but they start
attacking our audience and they say that
our
audience's views are condemnable
inexcusable
all sorts of language views which by the
way
no one's ever been quiet about and and
which it would seem that that
certain advertisers are just being
opportunistic when some random twitter
account says something about it
that's a very different thing
advertisers more more than free to
cancel whenever they want but when you
start going after
us in a really vicious way when you
start going after our listeners and our
audience
then unfortunately for the advertisers
we need to speak up
there used to be a time in this country
not that long ago
where when you engaged in free
associations with people and i'm not
even just talking about economic
arrangements i'm talking about civil
associations the pta the lions club
where
anywhere with your neighbors and the
neighborhood community that you didn't
have to have 100
perfect ideological conformity on
everything and that's a better country
that's the country that we want to live
in but
harry's i guess doesn't think we ought
to live in that country
harry's doesn't think that conservatives
deserve to have good razors
and you're you're free to make up your
mind with
what you'd like to do with that it's
kind of tough out there in the razor
game today
you've got you've got gillette uh
telling people uh that you should teach
your daughter to shave her face you've
got
harry's now saying that conservatives
don't have the right to to get good
razors
this this shrinking of the
private sphere where you can sort of
have different views with your neighbors
and that's okay
this this ideological ideologization
of everything well is that a word it'll
be a word now the the
i use that word because it's much more
specific but we sometimes call it the
politicization
of everything now including the razors
that i have to be condemned
by my razor company because i hold
perfectly ordinary views that most
people have held for
most of history about you know the
nature of man and the nature of these
gender questions that have become very
fashionable now
that that is a really sad thing and so
we're
really disappointed in that because we
we've got such great relationships with
all of our advertisers
the ones that agree with us on lots of
stuff the ones that don't agree with us
on lots of stuff
we just try to be good partners just
like we would be good neighbors with
anybody around us
uh you know whether we have a 100
conformity with them or zero percent
conformity with them
we try to be good neighbors and bring
people good products really uh really
unfortunate
that harry's thinks that conservatives
don't deserve good
razors on these questions uh and on this
one which is so
particularly hot right now the gender
question
you're going to see some some divide
among conservatives on it
christie gnome governor of south dakota
who has been a really strong governor
during kovid
she i think is trying to line herself up
for 2024.
she just made what i think is her first
really big mistake
she declined on friday to sign a bill
from legislators in her own party
that would ban boys who identify as
girls from participating in women's high
school sports
this of course because when boys compete
against girls
in sports of any kind they win because
men are
bigger and faster and stronger
physically than women
she sent out a statement about this she
said she wants changes she wants to
water the bill down she doesn't want to
apply to college
and this because there are such
prevailing wins in our culture
to erase the distinction between men and
women and this has a lot i mean just in
a very practical way
this means that women are not going to
win their trophies in in sports this
means they're going to
lose college scholarships this is gonna
this is gonna
have real tangible effects and it's also
just unjust in and of itself
because men and women really are
different and when you try to
when you erase that distinction you do
erase women
but because it's become so fashionable
such a hot button topic
christy gnome has gone squishy on it
this is going to be a big dividing line
in
2024. speaking of 2024 who who knows
even
who's going to be running on the other
side ben is going to be covering
president biden's fall down the stairs
today and all those migrant children as
well so go check out his show
also last week was a huge week for the
daily wire on friday candace owens
premiered her first episode
of her new talk show candace and so many
users
tuned in to watch this show that it
actually broke our website
it broke our live stream for a few
minutes if you have not seen it yet
you are definitely going to want to
check it out you can catch key segments
on her new podcast
canvas which is available on apple
podcast spotify or anywhere else you
listen
but and this is very important only
daily wire members can get the full show
go to dailywire.com subscribe and get 25
off a new membership with code candace
that's dailywire.com
subscribe and get 25 off with code
candace head on over to dailywire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
so christy gnome has gone squishy on
this gender ideology question
she is now refusing to sign a bill that
would prevent men from competing against
women in women's sports
a bill you know this new gender ideology
completely undermining
women's sports notably but the whole
distinction between men and women
and gnomes she's going a little squish
on it that's too bad because i think she
could be a pretty good candidate
but to win the nomination in 2024 you
need to be ready for prime time
another guy who would seem very clearly
to be gunning for the nomination ron
desantis is playing his cards much
better
desantis was asked a question about
vaccine passports
the idea that you would have to prove
that you've received the covid vaccine
in order to travel or
to engage in commerce ron desantis came
out and said
no way absolutely not the vaccine
passport is a terrible idea
we are definitely not going to require
anything from the state's perspective
that is totally off the table
if i have businesses that want to do
that in
florida i think that that's more than
just a private decision i think that
impacts our society i think that impacts
people particularly disadvantaged people
in a way that would barely be negative
for our state
so what form that would take i'd have to
discuss it with my folks i have to
discuss it potentially with the
legislature
but i think it's a very very bad idea
look
if you want to go to a movie theater or
concert all this stuff
go if you don't don't but to require
somebody to show
some type of proof of vaccination i
think is is completely unacceptable and
it's not something that we're going to
support here in any way in florida
really smart stuff really impressive
stuff i've said this about desantis you
know
we don't know that much about him he
hasn't been around a long time so before
everyone says okay he's the nominee
we got to make sure he's got the stamina
but that that's really good stuff
that's that's really impressive stuff
there because he's not falling into the
trap
the trap that conservatives fall into a
lot the trap that i describe
actually in my upcoming book speech list
controlling words controlling minds
which is available now for pre-order but
it probably won't be for much longer
once amazon figures out what's in the
book
what ron desantis is saying here is
we in the government of florida we are
not going to
have vaccine passports okay we're not
going to require you
to show that you got the vaccine but
further
if private companies or semi-private
companies start to require you to do
that
we don't think they should get away with
that either you know when
when amazon when big big technology
companies came in started clamping down
on conservatives started booting off the
dually elected sitting president of the
united states
and censoring him when when hipster
rasputin over there jack dorsey in
silicon valley said
i should be able to censor the president
of the united states there were
some squishes on the right who came out
and said
private company they can do whatever
they want there's no question here
it's come on it's fine if a handful of
billionaire oligarchs control the flow
of information around the public sphere
that's fine
they can do whatever they want it's a
free country no because they understand
that
while this may not be particularly or
specifically a first amendment issue
it does more broadly get to the issue of
american free speech
if i'm being censored and ostracized and
prevented from engaging in commerce and
politics
by a private company it's no better than
if the government does it to me i don't
care the effect of it is exactly the
same and the effect on our politics is
exactly the same
and desantis is coming out and saying no
they're actually
we're not going to just allow woke-ism
once it's
totally infected the government to then
just start flexing its muscles in the
universities and in
big tech and in corporate america we're
not going to do that we're trying to
conserve something here
in this country really really smart
stuff
two options in 2024 as i see it
is what what gnome is now leaning toward
which is
thinking that the future of conservatism
is slowly
accommodating modern progressive fads
that the future of conservatism is you
know getting sort of okay with the
with transgender ideology and yeah it
destroys women's sports and
it lets men go use the little girl's
bathroom you know that but we'll just we
got to do it slowly
as long as we accommodate that slowly
that's the future she's clearly putting
her chips on that bet
desantis saying something different he's
saying that the future of conservatism
is about recovering
something that is lost even if that
means
questioning comfortable gop talking
points about how
big private businesses like facebook and
google and amazon
can do whatever they want and we should
celebrate it and desantis here is right
however i still think we need to know
more about the guy
we should not we should not get too
excited about what's going on in 2024
just yet we need to see a longer track
record because these are very tricky
questions
and the public pressure is a lot you got
to make sure people can really really
stand up to that sort of thing
speaking of tough politicians we haven't
checked in on our old friend andy cuomo
in new york
he's a tough guy i've got to hand it to
him a lesser politician
would have already resigned a lesser
politician would have already been
outflanked by his party and he'd be gone
cuomo though standing firm he's saying
you got to impeach me to get me out of
here
i'm not going to do it democrats doing
everything they can
they're pretending that they're kicking
him out over this contrived sex scandal
actually they're kicking him out because
he totally blew it on kovid
and that exposes much more of them
because they were a part of that scandal
they promoted him during covid they
participated in some of his policies
so they're going to try to boot him for
the ridiculous sex thing
now the argument has changed
so many times one argument was
andy cuomo he made women uncomfortable
then it's
now he groped a woman or something then
it's that he
now they're saying that they want to
kick him out
because he's too tough because he
bullies people there was
there was audio that was leaked it was
leaked on that new york times podcast
that
absolutely unlistenable new york times
podcast that uh
that uh you know occasionally it's at
the top of the charts
but michael barbaro and blah blah blah
blah
and the new york times left-wing outlet
released this
uh tape which is cuomo talking to the
working families party in new york for
those who don't know what that is
it's like a communist front basically
this is as
radical left as you can possibly get in
new york and he's talking to them and
they say look
we'll endorse you but we got to say we
don't agree with you on everything and
he said okay you want to do that i'm
going to compare you to child rapists
if you ever say well he's better than a
republican again
i'm going to say you're better than a
child rapist how about that
governor i want to i apologize but i got
to clarify one thing you're free to say
whatever you want governor
um but but i just i just like want to be
clear
our line is going to be that we have
differences with you
but our differences with the republicans
are far greater
that's what we're going to continue to
say because that is
you know we don't have 100 agreement and
quite frankly governor we're very
comfortable with you saying the same
thing
you know you you probably think many of
our positions
you don't have to agree with us you're
better than a child i think you're
better than children
i just want you to know so now now the
democrats are trying to make this into a
scandal to try to keep pressure up on
cuomo
what's the scandal here he's saying
listen you jerks
you're you're giving me an endorsement
but it's a very
underhanded sort of endorsement you're
saying oh he's a little bit better than
republicans he goes you want to say that
i'm going to say you're a little bit
better than a child rapist
what's offensive with that that's just
tough politics and andy cuomo
is a notoriously tough politician in new
york
you got to give him credit for this and
the fact that they keep changing the
narrative well first it's this then it's
this now they're going after him for
being a bully i mean it just shows
that they they're they're desperate to
get him out because they don't want to
deal with the real issue
i think andy cuomo should be kicked out
of office i think that he is a very bad
leader
and i think that his views are abhorrent
on a great many things
and i think that he killed thousands of
elderly new yorkers
through terrible policies and then he
knew about it and then he covered it up
i don't think he should be impeached for
the contrived sex thing i don't think he
should be impeached because he was
talked tough to the working families
party don't let the democrats get away
with us
i don't think we should let them i think
we need to
expose them for the actual scandal
here because this has much broader
implications not just for new york
democrats
but for democrats around the country
speaking
of child abuse slate had
a letter you know a dear prudence letter
that
i i had to read on the air was so
disturbing and tells you so much about
our culture question is should i abort
my pregnancy and tell my husband i
miscarried
dear prudence i am happily married
financially stable and a mom of a
beautiful feral toddler
on a drunken night i convinced myself
that i did in fact want a sibling for my
toddler
quite the 180 from my staunch stance of
one and done i'm now 10 weeks pregnant
and my second child
with my second child and plagued by by
nausea vomiting and most of all regret
should i terminate this pregnancy
meaning should i kill the baby
and tell all including my husband that
i'm miscarried
he his parents and my parents are all
excited about baby number two
as they should be i however am
completely disappointed in myself for
having a lapse in judgment and thinking
i would be okay with getting pregnant
again
so much wrong here what she's asking is
i want to live this life where i only
have one child and i do not give all of
myself to my husband and he does not
give all of himself to me and we do not
in our love create new life
and we do not give this wonderful gift
of life which we've received to other
people
but accidentally we did that because at
least my natural
impulses overwhelmed my bizarre ideology
one night
and now i want to know should i kill my
baby and
lie to my husband and family about it
this should not be a difficult question
this should be a dear her name is
thinking about termination do you think
about termination
no sincerely yours prudence right that
should be the letter
but here's the first line of slate's
answer i don't want to be a parent is a
wholly sufficient reason to schedule an
abortion
you're under no obligation to disclose
your decision to terminate your
pregnancy to anyone else and it's yours
and it's fine and it's all you and you
should
you should have an abortion basically
the whole thing is so sad and so
mistaken because this miserable woman is
going to be even more miserable if she
does this and our culture is going to be
more miserable too if these ideas spread
it's just it's it's not even a question
of what should
i do or what should i be
it's we're getting it wrong on the basic
question of
what am i what is this woman they say i
don't want to be a parent is a holy
sufficient reason to schedule an
abortion
that's not a question the woman is
already a parent
she's a parent in that she has a toddler
so she's obviously already a parent
but the minute she gets pregnant she is
a parent
it would if the question were do i want
to be a parent or not be a parent
then that is much more complicated
much better argument for no maybe i want
to push this off for some time
but that isn't the question is much
starker and this woman doesn't want to
come to terms with it that's why she's
using euphemisms here
thinking about termination or whatever
and that's why slade is using
euphemisms here the question is should i
kill my kid and lie to my family
of course not just about the most wicked
thing you can do
but this gets to what we're always
talking about here the language
is what gives these ideologues
the cover to justify and rationalize
their
wicked abhorrent actions the language
does it
this is why political correctness
matters this is why
the transgender issue right is a
psychological matter it affects a very
small number of people
who are men who think they're women or
women who think they're men or who very
much desire to be so
but as a social and political matter
it's hugely important
this is why when people when squishy
conservatives and dishonest liberals
tell you
oh who cares the gender thing it's not a
big deal it doesn't matter
okay if it doesn't matter then how come
the left is spending so much time
and money and energy on it if it doesn't
matter
why why is the left spending all of this
energy to completely
invert our understanding of the most
basic fact of our nature
if it doesn't really matter because it
does matter because if you can
through language redefine a man as a
woman
you can redefine reality this is as i
may have mentioned even already in this
show
a topic of my book central topic of my
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds and i think that the
libs are going to
try to control the words and try to
continue to control our minds
by suppressing this book and they're
doing it because we have always fallen
into this trap of
not understanding what pc is and how
political correctness is an instrument
that gives the life a lot of power and
it's why
the harder the conservatives seem to
fight against it
the more we lose how even a
tough-as-nails
2024 candidate like christy gnome goes
squishy
because they don't get what this is
about
really sad stuff at a slate so you know
i suspect that woman doesn't listen to
my show
but maybe she should planned parenthood
comes out they just uh they
planned parenthood defended cardi b so
this relates uh quite a lot to what
we're hearing here
it says shout out to the iconic black
women using the power of pleasure as a
form of resistance
exactly the opposite is true here
pleasure is a good thing
pleasure comes from god right in its
proper place
when you make an idol out of pleasure
and when you give in
to your most base animalistic pleasures
and desires
that's the opposite of power that's the
opposite of resistance
that becomes a perversion of what could
be a good thing
you just know this if you give in to
drugs let's say you indulge your base
appetite for drugs and you shoot heroin
you become a heroin addict does that
mean you're powerful are you capable of
resistance then
no you lose your ability for resistance
same thing on sex
same thing on food same thing on all
manner of giving into our base
desires and planned parenthood knows
this
and the left knows this when they have
pushed
this kind largely through sex because
sex is such an important
uh aspect of our nature that's why
they're focused on the gender issue now
it's why they've been focused on the
sexual revolution
since the 1960s if you can get people
totally
riled up about their most basic animal
aspects and instincts then they lose
their capacity
for higher thinking for the ability to
control their will
for their ability to resist as always
what
group like planned parenthood says is
exactly the opposite of true
they the left gets everybody riled up
about sex and gets everybody riled up
about race
elizabeth warren the grand chief
of our united states senate
liawatha is now coming out and
attacking the filibuster the filibuster
is what slows things down in the senate
requires senators to get more votes than
a bare majority to go
along and advance legislation
it's been around for a long time it's
why the senate in many ways is
supposed to be the greatest deliberative
body in the world is that it's not as
impulsive as the house whereas the house
follows its more
uh animalistic instinct sometimes it's
closer to the people
and it's more given sway by emotion and
passion
the senate is supposed to be more
deliberative she wants to get rid of
that she says the filibuster has deep
roots in racism and it should not be
permitted to serve that function or to
create a veto for the minority
in a democracy it's majority rules
not really in our democracy i mean the
woman that clearly hasn't read the
constitution or the federalist papers
anytime recently or maybe she has and
she's just lying about it because we do
not have a simple majority worlds
government we have a intricate system of
checks and balances
an intricate system of a separation of
powers
where the the major they're
voting and the majority and there's a
democratic aspect but there are also
some
undemocratic aspects you see this much
more so in the judiciary
and theoretically in in the senate is
the states are supposed to elect the
senate not the people
at least in the original formulation but
the the irony here runs even deeper
she's saying the filibuster is racist
elizabeth warren has used the filibuster
at least three times
when it suited her she supported the
filibuster to block tim scott's police
reform bill
she supported the filibuster to block
billions in covid relief when
republicans were pushing it
she supported the filibuster to block
the
born alive abortion survivors protection
act
that would require doctors
who were unsuccessful in killing babies
in the womb
to not butcher them on the operating
table
she is the filibuster for that she
endorsed wendy davis
abortion barbie in texas
in part because of her quote famous
filibuster
so elizabeth warren has no issue with
the filibuster when it suits her purpose
and then when it doesn't she says it's
racist
she says it's racist because racism has
been
deprived basically of all meaning
it is the worst thing that you can call
somebody in america today and so it is
just a term that the left uses
as a synonym for bad and if you point
this out this hypocrisy do you know what
she'll do
she'll shrug her shoulders she doesn't
care
because she knows that it's only
conservatives who care about being
called racist
right it's the left doesn't care
they just say nope no way that's the
word that we use to control you not not
the other way around so she's going to
use it
and you can't make a reasonable argument
then if elizabeth warren is saying
i'm just going to be dishonest i'm just
going to i'm going to do one thing
and i'm going to then speak in a way
that would contradict it
and if you yell at me about it or you
call hypocrisy i just don't care
well in that case deliberation is not
possible and
this is why you're seeing on the left a
push toward
in our government bodies less
deliberation
in our immigration policy for one just
flooding people ignoring the law to give
them
a bare bones interest majority you see
the undermining of of objective truth
smithsonian institution comes out and
says yeah objective truth that's a term
of white supremacy
you you see grades are a form of white
supremacy
uh mathematical concepts form of white
supremacy so
all your your base instincts your
pleasure your most
animalistic desires that's the way you
resist right so just suppressing your
reason
increasing your appetites because at
that point politics does not become
a way of persuading one another through
reasonable ideas
it becomes a battle of interest and
brute force and that's the politics the
left wants
that's the politics they're getting
speaking of racism
the georgetown men's basketball team
along with their coach the whole team
and their coach
took a knee before the national anthem
ahead of the
ncaa tournament game against colorado on
saturday
then they lost to colorado 96-73
good glad to hear that that's a silver
lining in this very
stormy story the kneeling for the flag
is a sign of disrespect i know some
disingenuous libs pretend that isn't the
case
but colin kaepernick who started the
whole protest said that
he says i am not going to stand up to
show pride in a flag for a country that
oppresses black people and people of
color
to me this is bigger than football so
he's saying when i stand up that shows
pride in my country and when we say
national pride what are we talking about
we're talking about
loyalty to the country we're talking
about patriotism we're talking about
love for the country
i'm not going to do that i'm going to
kneel down because i don't like this
country
and what these guys this georgetown
basketball team is doing is they're
saying i don't like my country
and i'm going to disrespect my country
now
if georgetown is receiving any taxpayer
money
they should lose that money the students
who did this
should be punished they should i hope be
kicked off the team
if not expelled from the school entirely
if the school administrators
do not punish these students for this
anti-american display
the school should lose its federal
funding and conservatives should be
willing
to push for this sort of thing we have
fallen into the trap
of political correctness whereby we
either embrace their new standards which
are disrespect the flag deny
biological sex deny this deny that
or we give up standards altogether and
we say well
free speech academic freedom whatever
first of all the modern conservative
movement began when bill buckley called
academic freedom a hoax
said it was a superstition in god and
man at yale
but moreover there is a thought that
stops thought okay we have to have
standards here
it is better to love our country than to
hate our country and if you hate your
country long enough you're not going to
have a country anymore so we need to
encourage people to love their country
we all did that in this country not not
even just conservatives but even
liberals did that in this country for a
long time now we're pretending we're not
allowed to say that
there's nothing hypocritical about
preferring the good
and discouraging evil
and bad things it's perfectly ordinary
it's what every political regime does
okay that's what conservatives need to
get more comfortable saying
and you're seeing some bubbling up of
this
when desantis says what he said about
vaccine passports
when president trump in his presidency
said we need to stand for things we need
to make america great again you know we
got to like we got to love our
communities we need
we want good things we want to go we
want to hug that american flag right
and this would also happen to be the
thesis of my book speechless
that i think is the future that is the
if if conservatism is to have a future
the country's going to have a future
that that is going to be the future
otherwise we're just giving up
and rolling over to the left in crisis
after crisis
after crisis that's our show i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show